اذا هذا وجه اخر للحرب الاوكرانيه او
انشئنا الدقه هو عارض جانبي وساحته
افريقيا لكن المواجهه هنا ليست عسكريه
وانما استراتيجيه تتعلق بالنفوذ وتحديدا
في القاره السمراء فما يحدث من تقلبات في
نفوذ القوى العظمى داخل هذه القاره يؤكد
بان يوضعا جديدا من التحالفات يتم نسجه
روسيا التي تعيش صراع عن حقيقيا مع القوى
الغربيه بسبب عمليتها العسكريه في
اوكرانيا وجهت البوصله بشكل واضح لو نحو
الدول الافريقيه بحثا عن خلفاء جدد
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في التغلغل في
افريقيا بدات عام 2020 عندما لجا رئيس
افريقيا الوسطى همم فلسطين
الى موسكو من اجل دعمه للبقاء في الحكم
التجربه الروسيه تكررت في مالي عقب انقلاب
الكونونال السيميتا
في 2020 الذي تم بمسانده روسيه دون ان
نانسي انضمام بوركينا فاسو الى دائره نفوذ
الروسي مؤخرا بعد دعم موسكو الانقلاب الذي
انتهى بتعيين ابراهيم تروري رئيسا للمجلس
العسكري في اخر خطوه روسيا لمد الجسور مع
القاره السمراء الجوله الافريقيه لوزير
الخارجيه الروسي سرجيا لافراف التي
استهلها من جنوب افريقيا علما انها الجوله
الافريقيه الثانيه للافراف في اقل من عمد
زياره لافراف ليبريتوريا حملت عنوان عريضه
باهتمام كبير وهو الاعلان عن تدريبات
عسكريه مشتركه بين روسيا والصين وجنوب
افريقيا ستقام على الساحل الشرقي لجنوب
افريقيا في وقت لاحق من شهر فبراير المقبل
هي تدريبات التي دافعت عنها وزيره خارجيه
جنوب افريقيا
باندور بالقول ان استضافه مثل هذه
التدريبات مع الاصدقاء تمثل المسار
الطبيعي لهذا العلاقه
انسى ان النفود العسكريه الروسي في
افريقيا توسع من خلال قوات
ڤاجنر التي بات تنتشر في الكثير من
البلدان علما بان هذا التوسع لفاكنر جاء
بعد انحسار تواجد القوات الاجنبيه الاخرى
وفي مقدمتها القوات الفرنسيه التي تستعد
لمغادره بوركينا فاسو بطلب من الاخير هو
انسحاب في سلسله من الانسحابات الفرنسيه
من القاره كانت حلقتها السابقه من مال
المجاوره